[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mac for
anime uproar and this will be the first
in a series of videos where I look at
some of the greatest villains in anime
including both modern and classic anime
and in these videos I will try to
explain what makes a great villain and
why these particular villains grab our
attention and keep us thinking about
them long after the story ends or if the
story is ongoing long after they have
played their particular part in the
story in a previous video I asked you
guys to tell me on Twitter and Instagram
who your favorite anime villains are and
stain from boku no hero was a popular
choice I think that stain is the perfect
villain to start with because he is
featured in a series that is currently
ongoing but stain himself only had a
brief role in both the anime and manga
before being arrested and effectively
taken out of the picture at least for
now
and yet stain is often referred to as a
great villain character by the fanbase
and many consider him to be the best
villain in boku no hero to date despite
his brief presence in the actual story
so in this video I will explore what
exactly makes stain a memorable
character and why he made such a big
impression both on the fictional world
of the story and on boku no hero fans in
the real world if you'd like to suggest
villains that I should cover in future
videos just hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime out Pro and let me
know which villain you think should be
next and why and now let's get started
the first thing that we need to do is
address the terminology I have seen many
people referring to stain as an antihero
rather than a villain so let's clarify
there are different definitions
depending on who you ask but in general
the term antihero refers to a central
character usually the protagonist of a
story who does not have traditional
heroic qualities basically he is not a
conventional good guy who just wants to
help others and do good things at least
he doesn't start out
some examples of this include spike from
Cowboy Bebop who is a former gangster
and current bounty hunter with whatever
happens happens approach to life and
also a great teacher onizuka who at the
beginning of the story is a former gang
member who becomes a high school teacher
so that he can hit on hot girls but
onizuka's character later develops into
a more conventional hero as the story
goes on some would say that a vigilante
like The Dark Knight Returns version of
Batman is an antihero because although
he is fighting evil he is doing it
outside the confines of the law and
sometimes he crosses the line like
torturing a criminal for information
however even a vigilante type antihero
like Batman still has a clear rule about
not killing at least in the modern
version of the comics the reason that I
would classify Stane as a villain rather
than an antihero is that one he is not a
central character and in fact one of the
interesting things about him is how
briefly he appears in the story and yet
still leaves an important impact and to
stain regularly kills or is prepared to
kill people who are not necessarily evil
all in the name of his ideology it would
be one thing if stain was killing only
dangerous criminals who are a threat to
the safety of society but stain is
prepared to kill someone like tensei eda
a pro hero who is generally speaking a
good guy and helps others and cares
about his family stain may think that
tenses motives for being a hero are not
pure enough but it is one thing to have
a different opinion on what it means to
be a hero and quite another to try to
kill those who have a different opinion
than you do even if they are not
themselves bad people stain believes
that what he is doing is right he
believed that he is purging society from
those who became Heroes for the wrong
reasons but his actions still make him a
villain even though his motivations can
be seen as noble stain takes it upon
himself to judge which heroes are worthy
and which heroes should essentially
receive the death penalty even though he
doesn't necessarily know the individuals
he is judging so he can't possibly
understand what is truly
their heart because of this stain could
be classified as an anti villain which
is a term that refers to the type of
villain who has heroic motivations and
is trying to achieve something good in
stains case to cleanse a corrupt society
but the means that he uses to achieve
his goals are evil such as killing or
trying to kill Pro heroes like ten
sayyeda although we can certainly debate
whether someone like Tensei became a
hero for the right reasons to say that
he deserves to die goes far beyond what
a hero of any kind even an antihero
could reasonably conclude and of course
we can't confuse an antihero with a
villain protagonist a person who is a
central character in the story but is
actually a villain rather than a hero
like Tanya from yojo Sankey so having
said all this why is stains such a
memorable and impactful villain not only
is he popular among the MHA fanbase but
he is also extremely popular within the
fictional world of boku no hero and his
actions directly inspire a new
generation of villains including
individuals like dobby Tolga and spinner
shizume a kaguro better known as stain
was greatly inspired by all might in his
early years and he even enrolled in a
private hero academy because he wanted
to become a true hero like all mine
however once at school stain realized
that many of his classmates wanted to
become heroes for the wrong reasons
instead of trying to selflessly help
others stains classmates wanted to
become heroes for their own selfish
interests they wanted money Fame and
power stains soon realized that the hero
society is deeply flawed in a world
where being a pro hero is a highly
respected position a position that comes
with money power and fame many
individuals were not truly heroic but
selfish and vain embraced the pro hero
profession many of the people who are
supposed to be protecting society and
defending the defenseless were actually
self-interested money-hungry
fame-seeking
opportunists who didn't even care about
the people they were supposed to be
protecting a good example of this would
be the flame hero endeavor someone who
was driven by ambition
and a selfish desire to surpass all
night instead of the desire to help
others and someone who is cruel and
abusive towards his own family in his
personal life but in public is known as
a top-ranked pro hero with more
successfully resolved cases than any
other hero after dropping out of the
hero Academy Chisolm had tried to shine
a light on the corruption of the hero
society by speaking out about it on
street corners and trying to persuade
people to see the truth but he didn't
manage to build a significant following
and his words were largely ignored this
was another major blow to Chisolm a and
after failing to make a difference
through nonviolent means he decided to
promote his principles by turning to
violence for a period of time Chisolm I
became a vigilante and as a vigilante he
set out to correct the mistakes of the
hero society by taking justice into his
own hands in his role as a vigilante he
brutally murdered criminals without
remorse but it wasn't long before Keizo
met changed his strategy instead of
killing criminals he began to murder the
pro heroes that he judged to be corrupt
and motivated by selfish goals and he
soon became known as the hero killer
stained stains ideology known as the
revival of heroics holds that true
heroes must be driven by a selfless
desire to help others and they must be
prepared to sacrifice themselves in the
name of saving others Pro heroes who
were interested in benefiting themselves
and were not prepared to sacrifice
themselves for others were deemed
unworthy by staying and during his
campaign of violence
Stane murdered 17 pro heroes and
severely injured 23 others it is
important to note however that stain
does not believe all Pro heroes are
corrupt he still believes that all night
is a true hero and he also respects
others who are trying to become Heroes
for the right reasons because of this
not only the stain not harmed deku but
because stain considers that who worthy
of becoming a true hero he even risks
his own life to save that goof from the
winged nomal in that sense we can see
that stain is not all bad he believes
that what he is doing needs to be done
to save society from corruption and
decay many of us can relate
to the points that stain is trying to
get across in our own society there are
many people who became wealthy and
famous by exploiting others by cheating
the system and so on I mean just look at
the banking system and how the same
individuals who ripped off thousands of
people ended up being bailed out by the
government because their companies were
too big to fail stain makes a good point
a point that resonates with many people
both in the world of boku no hero and in
our own world but here is the problem
stain takes it upon himself to judge who
is good and who was bad who is worthy
and who was unworthy and he is willing
to kill those individuals that he deems
unworthy while that might seem appealing
if you are the one doing the judging
imagine what the world would look like
if everyone took justice into their own
hands in the same way that stain does
there is no way that someone you haven't
even met can tell what is in your heart
there is no way for them to judge what
your true motivations are and yet if we
accept stains methods then we might find
ourselves in a society full of
vigilantes who are willing to kill
everyone they deem unworthy how long
before someone accuses you or me of also
being unworthy how long before someone
comes for us because they decided to
judge us before even getting to know us
the reason that laws were established in
the first place was that a society in
which everyone took the law into their
own hands led to other chaos you would
have to constantly look over your
shoulder in case someone decided that
you had done something wrong
and there would be no court of law where
you could argue your point and prove
your innocence so a world full of stains
would not necessarily be a great place
to live in just like a world full of
corrupt Pro Heroes has a lot of
drawbacks and this is the essence of
what makes tane such a great villain he
is not just evil but he is not just good
either he makes some excellent points
and identifies some real problems but
his solutions create their own problems
as well state is not one-dimensional he
is complex nuanced and Hume
we can all relate to some of the things
that he believes we can sympathize with
his ultimate goal even if we don't agree
with all of his methods there are four
major factors that I believe make a
great villain not all of them apply to
every great villain and some great
villains even subvert these categories
but here they are as I see them number
one is motivation does the villain have
a goal that drives him or her and is
this goal something that we can
understand and relate to if we put
ourselves in the villains shoes would we
understand how they feel there are a few
great villains out there who are just
evil for the sake of being evil like for
example Johan Lee Byrd from Monster but
much more often a villain who is evil
for the sake of being evil is
one-dimensional and boring
Stane definitely has a clear and
relatable ideology an ideology that
drives his actions
Stane wants the streets to run red with
the blood of hypocrites and even if you
disagree with his methods you can kind
of see where he's coming from and that
is a powerful factor in whether or not
we end up liking or hating a villain
number two is backstory does the
villains upbringing an earlier life
explain at least to some extent how they
became the person they are today with
stain we see a person who was inspired
to become a true hero like all might but
he was devastated to learn that most
people around him only wanted to become
heroes for selfish reasons this had a
profound psychological impact on stain
and after his attempts to change society
for the better through nonviolent means
failed and he was ignored stain decided
to turn to violence number three his
personality is the villain an
interesting character
do we feel excitement and tension when
he is on stage or is he boring monotone
forgettable and so on when we look at
stain we see the kind of awe and fear
that he brings out in others as soon as
he appears his unrivaled determination
and extreme conviction give off a
palpable aura that is felt by everyone
around him he has a commanding presence
and a piercing glare that is enough to
freeze even an experienced hero like
endeavor
in his tracks stained definitely has the
type of gripping personality and
presence that keeps us as viewers on the
edge of our seats and that is why after
the hero killer arc ends we are left
wanting more and number four is power is
the villain powerful enough to be a
challenge to the heroes without being so
overpowered than once the heroes defeat
him it feels contrived and we are left
thinking that the only reason the
villain lost was the power of friendship
I think that stain strikes the perfect
power balance as far as a villain is
concerned compared to many other quirks
like one for all or he'll flame stains
quirk blood curdle isn't that impressive
in order to activate his quirk stain has
to obtain some of his opponents blood
and then lick it or drink it after he
does this the opponent will be paralyzed
but only for a brief period of time
comparing this to something like
producing massive flames or having
superhuman strength
leaves much to be desired however
through rigorous training stain is able
to become an extremely powerful villain
he has unrivaled speed and impeccable
technique and this is what gives him an
edge over heroes with far stronger
quirks through hard work and commitment
stain is able to maximize the potential
of his quirk and even though he is a
villain we are left with a sense of
respect for his work ethic and
determination and this is why I believe
that stain is a great villain and why I
want to see more of him in the future
after stain was arrested his ideology
was hijacked by shigaraki and the league
of villains in order to recruit
individuals who were inspired by stain
even though she kuraki actually despises
stain and doesn't care about his
ideology at all it would be fascinating
to see how stain would react to the fact
that his ideology is being misused by
the league of villains and how he would
deal with people like him ago toga who
claimed to be inspired by him but who
appeared to have other underlying
motives for the things that they are
doing I would love to see stains somehow
escape prison and then have to deal with
the consequences of his actions and
everything that happened after he was
incarcerated it is likely that this
would force stain to reevaluate how his
ideas are
interpreted and what kind of impact he
is actually having on society which
would lead him to further develop as a
character but let me know what you guys
think do you agree that stain is a great
villain why or why not
and what other villains do you want me
to cover in the future feel free to
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar and tell me which villains
you think deserve a video of their own
and why if you enjoy this video you want
to see more videos like this be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell by the way this type
of analytical video doesn't usually get
a lot of views here on the channel but I
really enjoy making them and I will
continue to do so in the future if you
really like these analytical videos and
you want to see them more often
I am restructuring the anime opera
patreon to support analytical content
feel free to check out the patreon link
in the description and from now on every
analytical video of this type will be
sponsored in part by the anime uproar
patrons and I will thank all the patrons
in the video itself every little bit
helps and we will be offering some cool
rewards as well as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]